question when you do the BET Cipher mhm
who was your Cipher with um so DJ head
was the DJ M and then I did it with the
Mexican OT and Lenell Grant yo that
Mexican OT is hard yeah I couldn't
understand anything he was saying did
you did you guys talk yeah did he say
what's up
baby yes he's so like Southern I love it
on Sunday or no Friday we're flying to
Houston mhm and um I'm scared cuz I'm an
animal lover but in
Texas they're they have these pigs that
are like invasive uh breed of pigs that
like ruin all the crops and like kill uh
like pets and [__] so I'm going to fly
to Texas on
Friday and go hog hunting with that
Mexican
OT yeah
I kind of feel the same way but you know
I'm going to that does not sound fun I
know but someone's going to kill the
Hogs if hey if it's not at least I get
the content you know that's true yeah I
do feel bad though I told I told OT I
said hey bro like do they like pick him
up and like cook him or anything like
you know so I at least feel better like
are we just killing these [__] Hogs
to kill them he's like nah bro we kill
them and leave them there I'm like oh
that sounds terrible can we cook and
make some tereso burritos or something
oh my God that is equally disgusting I
don't eat pork you don't like the swine
I don't eat pork no pork on my Fork the
swine is divine hell no [__] that you
never ate the swine I don't eat pork you
like turkey
bacon oh oh it's not a thing turkey
bacon is [__] terrible that's not
true have you ever had real bacon I
don't like- you've never had I don't do
pork I had Bon actually I got a a a
burger this was months ago probably like
a year ago now and I don't eat bacon I
don't eat pork period so I bit into my
burger and I was like this burger is
salty like a [__] like why do it
taste like this bacon bacon inside oh my
God I could have cried so you've never
just had a piece of bacon by itself in
your life no I this is this is this is
well you know what you're missing out I
just want to let you know that bacon
that bacon be smacking [__] that the
swine is divine [__] that run hey all
right more Pig for
me go ahead cook that pig oh I love what
is like one food like uh me and my
co-host on my radio show James we were
just talking about this cuz this past
weekend I had um I was in
Florida and uh you know like I'll be out
here I'll be thinking I'm doing good
eating right and [__] and then I'll go
to like hit the road and I'll Just Fall
the [__] off cuz I had pizza is the one
thing I could never get rid of like any
what is your favorite like if you if you
there was was a food you just had to put
it top tier you know what I'm saying mac
and cheese oh yeah I love mac and cheese
yo mac and cheese if you go to certain
restaurants they got lobster mac and
cheese it's like I don't like none of
that I you don't like the lobster mac
and cheese straight regular homemade
baked mac and cheese do you make a good
mac and cheese I make a great Mac do I
make a good mac and cheese there's a
great science to that back to my my my
white family my mom and my sister like
they think they make great mac and
cheese right they think they do but they
don't because have you ever said this to
your mom and sister kind
of yeah it's giving [__] kind of you
should call your mom and just be like
Mom Mom your mac and cheese is ass yeah
yeah exactly yeah cuz then like you know
give it to we straight my wife's mac and
cheese is fire she she's Mexican but she
cooks mac and cheese uh like soul food
style it's [__] that was racist I was
going to say you saying you want to say
something racist right now that was RAC
my wife but she she cooks backc and
cheese like a black
lady she does she does I need like a
button right now so I could be like
every time Kev says something I'm
racist no can't say that so um